prince william
game face on was back in front of the
cameras
putting his anger with the bbc and his
personal feelings to one side
as he began a week of visits in scotland
his criticism had been damning not just
as princess diana's son
but as an heir to the throne what
saddens me most
is that if the bbc had properly
investigated the complaints and concerns
first raised in 1995 my mother would
have known that she had been deceived
she was failed not just by a rogue
reporter but by leaders of the bbc
who looked the other way rather than
asking the tough questions
the prime minister during a visit to hms
queen elizabeth responded to the royal
intervention
and called for action from the bbc
well i am obviously concerned by the
findings of lord dyson's
uh report i'm very grateful to him for
uh for what he's done
i can only imagine the feelings of the
of the royal family
and i hope very much that the bbc will
be taking
every possible step to make sure that
nothing like this ever happens again
26 years after princess diana sat down
with martin beshear
we now know he used fake bank statements
to convince her
and her brother she was being spied on
and bbc bosses then covered up his
deceit
and lies it means questions for the
likes of james harding who was director
of bbc news
when beshear was rehired in 2016
after he'd left the corporation i didn't
know
and in fact if i had known of course he
wouldn't have got the job
i can't help feeling that the fact that
he was hired back in 2016
has made things more difficult for
everyone so i'm sorry that he was
lord dyson's report as i understand and
as i've read
actually spoken to lord hall at some
length in terms of the rehiring
the rehiring was done by bbc news i ran
bbc news the responsibility for it sits
with me
prince harry in his statement blamed
unethical
tactics for ultimately leading his
mother's death
when you speak to those who really push
for this inquiry they feel
even more justified in their actions
because of those responses from prince
william
and prince harry but william in
particular will have thought very
carefully
about what he had to say the royal
family don't pick
public battles unless it's about
something that
matters to them dearly publicly prince
william may feel he
said his peace his focus over the coming
days will be on representing the queen
in his eyes the interview created an
ongoing false narrative
and that still needs to be addressed by
the bbc
rhiannon mills sky news in edinburgh